what's going on reject nation greg
here so i just finished filming a
reaction for mid samar which uh
i'm gonna put up here on youtube and
then i called my brother back is he
calling while i was filming this movie
reaction and he's like hey there was a
mandalorian trailer that came out
a couple hours ago i still need to film
my review for midsummer
so right now i'm shaking that
piece of positivity off of my nerves
right now
and i'm gonna have a little bit of a
pallet cleanser to watch this 30 second
trailer of the mandalorian which we will
be covering for
youtube when it premieres it's because
it's the mandalorian man season two
super excited for it let's watch this
it's a weird evening for me guys dark
saber
it will be mine
damn that music um
[Applause]
whoa jet packing it up
whoa whoa wait a minute i gotta see that
shot there oh damn you see that moment
where
grief karga is like using uh a weapon
it looks like out of the ship maybe the
razor crest or maybe a different ship
kind of mirroring that moment with
luke skywalker i got one oh hell yeah
oh it's gonna be i bet that's gonna be
an epic space battle it's alluding to a
space battle
or something an aerial fight of sorts i
mean the highlight shot of this one has
to be with the doors opening and you got
grief cargo amanda with the man with
that
sexy armor that he's got on nikara dune
as well
buddy can't wait for this season i love
that these trailers are not telling you
much i mean there's channels like new
rock stars that are going to be able to
really
break down every single moment 101
things that you missed in the
mandalorian new trailer
i think in terms of marketing and doing
a trailer like they have this color
for footage from season one opening up
here with moff gideon using the dark
saber saying you have something i want
the chase to hunt down
mando and baby yoda or whatever baby
yoda's real name is i'm sure we'll find
out what the child's real name is in
this season and i love that shot that
they have where the color palette is
changing like we're going from season
one directly
into season two and all the chaos that's
gonna ensue from there but man man those
armor's looking
sharp didn't jarred man you're looking
sexy i wonder if that's the same moment
because
when he's like uh when he's jetpacking
away and there's this big explosion
going off which looks like mando set the
explosion the storm troopers were
shooting at him i wonder if that's from
the same moment where the
storm troopers are on on the ship and
going after him and they got kind of
that dutch angle moment mandalorian
season two
can't wait can't wait i gotta go review
bits tomorrow now keep a lookout for
whenever that reaction's up hoping to
have it up on the weekend
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell
catch you guys soon
[Music]
you